[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un truc comme ça qu'on arrive
en moyenne selon une étude les Français
feraient
que je suis le chef j'ai pas d'ici et
pour certains le plaisir charnel et même
pris très au sérieux en Suède le gérant
de plusieurs clubs de strip-tease a
décidé de créer une fédération suédoise
du sexe et d'organiser aujourd'hui un
championnat européen c'est un sport
comme un autre c'est parfaitement normal
de s'entraîner et de faire des
compétitions de sexe
au programme de l'après-midi farniente
et drague Arthur allume tout de suite
son radar
je mets le satellite
une compétition qui prévoyait notamment
une série d'épreuves à effectuer pendant
45 minutes mais ça demande d'en faire
officiellement un sport national a été
finalement refusé par l'État sur sa
gauche trois jeunes filles qui viennent
juste d'arriver
[Musique]
déception les trois filles sont trop
jeunes pour sortir le soir pour Arthur
et ses copains ce n'est pas encore gagné
l'origine du mot masturbation qui vient
du Latinus la main et trou raré pollué
en gros masturbation va dire ce polluer
par la main incroyable ça veut dire
sachez aussi qu'un collégien vous coûte
8206 euros par an et il vous coûte 6
mois avec sur 6 si vous êtes Jean-Marc
Morandini bref on apprend plein de
choses donc ça c'est à l'origine latine
et il y a eu au 18e siècle carrément un
traité pseudo-médical qui qui parlait de
ça et qui mais qui vous expliquait très
très sérieusement que se masturber pour
les hommes parce qu'on parlait carrément
pas de la masturbation
que ça pouvait appauvrir le sperme et
aussi à couvrir le cerveau autre cliché
qui a la vie dure la dégustation du vin
46% des hommes se chargent de le goûter
contre seulement 9% pour les femmes
parce que le seul animateur qui a jamais
voulu faire quoi que ce soit avec moi
c'est TOI d'ailleurs c'était un peu
vexant
[Applaudissements]
la jeunesse en panne de libido entre
angoisse existentielle puritanisme
concurrence des réseaux sociaux et porno
sur internet le désir se délite c'est
une amie on est comme ça
et donc pour vous dire
dans une catégorie et là je suis très
content parce qu'on va parler bouffes
je suis la reine des quiches et du
guacamole les deux vont penser
Louison je préfère croire que c'est que
pour la nourriture nous les
quarantenaires et 59 il y a pas de
preuve
c'est très intéressant c'est que il y a
eu cette génération qui était d'ailleurs
plutôt moi la génération de mes parents
60 68 heures entre guillemets ou au
contraire c'était jouir sans empire
libération des corps on fait ce qu'on
veut et cetera
d'une très grande ouverture
cousine c'est vrai parce que
effectivement leurs parents étaient
moins croyants pas du tout croyant mais
vous avez des gamins quelque part qui se
cherche qui cherche une qui veulent
retourner à l'identité de leur
grand-parents et qui et ben on choisit
et ben on va pas on est quand on est
descendant de musulmans on va pas
choisir de devenir chrétien ou juifs
des nouvelles rassurances du pape
François après son opération pour une
hernie abdominale il va mieux selon son
médecin puisqu'il a je cite très sérieux
fait sa première blague et bien figurine
qu'on nous étions les seuls à être
présent pour capturer ce moment des
images exclusives
non
bravo François
mais c'est pas les journalistes
de vous on a plus besoin de porte-parole
on n'a pas besoin de gens qui qui sont
là qui doivent nous dire comment on doit
s'habiller comment on doit penser on a
on a le droit de s'habiller comment tu
respectes parfaitement votre liberté ne
vous énervez pas qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce
que ce chrétien d'Orient prétendu
chrétien d'Orient parce que je ne suis
pas sûr qu'il soit vraiment chrétien il
s'est déclaré chrétien comme d'autres se
déclarent homosexuels comme d'autres
parce qu'ils ont compris que les
catégories qui nous permettent et qui
nous qui nous qui nous en nous tente et
qui nous que l'on que l'on favorise et
que l'on et que l'on accueille plus
favorablement quand on parle du loup oh
là là là on envoie le bout de la queue
en arrêtant de gueuler c'est un exemple
tu vois si tu cries moins logiquement
les cordes vocales ça ça revient merci
en tout cas d'avoir appelé je suis
désolé de vous soyez mis dans cet état
là on a souvent débattu ensemble Nassera
et c'est vrai que habituellement ça a
toujours toujours fait dans le dans un
certain respect là vous avez eu l'air
presque de dire que c'était contre nous
les journalistes et qu'il fallait
s'émanciper de nous comme si c'était un
combat entre un nous hypothétique et un
vous hypothétique je ne vis absolument
pas comme ça et je trouve ça très
injuste
c'est trop dur
habillées de manière européenne le monde
a des universités elles étudient elles
revendiquent une liberté d'expression de
tenue pas de soumission et ici on est en
train de se faire envahir par des modes
Qatariens parce qu'il y a beaucoup de
jeunes filles pour dire ce qui est qui
suivent sa sous prétexte d'une mode
en façades ils sont tellement doux et
gentils qu'on s'y attend pas c'est des
grands malades voici mes cinq règles
pour sortir avec un ou une vierge les
vierge peuvent manquer de fun et de
fantasy et il sera donc opportun de leur
rappeler de péter un coup pour croquer
la vie à pleines dents ce film elles
sont elles pensent que c'est un
déguisement je veux dire un moment donné
il faut penser aux gens qui sont au
lycée qui sont de conditions musulmanes
mais de compression musulmane dans le
coeur comme c'est mon cas à moi
[Musique]
c'est qui les personnalités préférées
des Français c'est qu'il y a Mbappé
c'est Yannick Noah
origines d'autres pays ce sont les
fruits de limite en France leurs parents
leurs parents de ces personnes que je
vous cite ne sont pas
je trouve que ça allait dans le même
sens
on est sur
tout va bien sûr bien sûr nous
résisterons
faut aller chercher les infos